hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel wet today I wanted to talk
about a Spider Man for ps4 actually
because of a question a lot of people
asked me that I really wasn't expecting
me to get so I'm excited to talk about
it anyway because it was one of my like
top five games that I got to play at e3
2018 it was a lot of fun but the
question that I keep getting that I
really wasn't expecting to get was
people asking me to compare it to the
Occam games how does it hold up against
Arkham Asylum against on from City
against all night
less so questions about akhom origins
even though I totally liked that game I
guess I understand where it's coming
from if people are asking from a place
of you know those are the only good
offline superhero games that exist but
to me it doesn't feel necessarily in the
same vein less so than I expected when
it came to combat - it feels a lot like
an insomniac game obviously it's made my
insomniac games but it feels more
accurate to me to describe it as an
insomniac game then it's superhero game
even though it probably sounds dumb but
let's talk about some of the biggest
differences between spider-man on ps4
and the Batman Arkham series and I want
to go into this by saying that Batman
Arkham Asylum is probably one of my
favorite games ever I adore that game so
first things first
obviously traversal is a very important
part of spider-man and I was so curious
to see how it would feel but also really
excited to see how it would feel because
I really like sunset overdrive which is
a game that is so good about giving you
this sense of fluidity as you wander the
world if you have a blade sunset
overdrive you can basically like you
kind of you could skate across
everything basically it seems like you
get from one point of the map to the
other without ever really touching the
ground that game really encourages you
to do we have tricks and flips and you
know get creative with your traversal
and spider-man sort of comes from the
same place in terms of that but I want
to say is more about momentum so when
you're swinging through the city which
is how the demo I played started out it
is so satisfying I was playing with a
friend who's sitting next to me at the
time and they're just moments where both
of us would just sort of be like oh my
god
basically as you start swinging it very
naturally finds points in the world for
you to rip your web onto and you really
feel that idea of a kind of pendulum
wait.you while building speed as you dip
down and then flip up and you keep
rising and obviously it's unrealistic
the amount of momentum you can build up
from one swing is crazy but because of
that it just feels really fast and
swinging I want to say is is very easy
it seems like you can latch on to
anything and everything
there were times where I plummeted
towards the ground but for the most part
it's very easy to see something to swing
and then run across the side of a
building and then leap off of that into
the end as this move where you can like
pull yourself towards a perch and you
can like sort of just shoot two webs at
it and then pull yourself forward and
then just keep going with that momentum
whereas obviously the akhom games kind
of do the opposite of that when it comes
to gliding I still had a lot of fun
gliding but the momentum slows down as
you glide rather than it being this this
build up I mean even when you're going
towards the ground in spider-man it's
like Criterion levels of like showing
you the speed where you're plummeting
towards the ground in the world is just
moving up around you I can't even
explain how good it feels but it does
feel like every new swing that you take
is building towards that sense of
momentum and you know the Aachen games
even when Knight was quite open there
are always areas that you couldn't go to
because there was snipers on the
rooftops of people on the streets where
is in spite a man being that he's your
friendly neighborhood spider-man it
feels like the world isn't particularly
hostile like you are free to swing
around that city it is your city and
maybe as the campaign goes on nobody
moments for those areas that you can't
go to without being attacked but it
definitely felt just very much all in
with you having fun with that system so
the way it comes to combat I expected
this to feel pretty similar to the
Arkham games and there are things in
common it has a vaguely familiar
countess system spidey-sense like
tingles above your head and you know
that someone who's going to shoot at you
or what have you
dodging is very quick and it does have
that sense of momentum with combat as
well where you punch someone it seems
like every punch you're kind of moving
further and further and and it's just
building up but the biggest difference
with spider-man one thing that I really
like about it is that a lot of your
punches seem to go toward
verticality basically a lot of your
moves are designed with the ability to
uppercut someone or web shoot someone
and have them up in the air when you can
really bring them up and you can shoot a
web with them and throw them back at the
ground or like pull someone and knock
them into someone else
it's just a lot of sort of instead of
you necessarily gliding around like
Batman does which you still can do a
Spidey he's very very agile it feels a
little more like you can move the other
enemies around environments a whole lot
including like pinning one guy up
against a wall waiting you know sort of
sealing him there with your web and then
going and attacking someone else who's
maybe on like a second story and just
like jumping all over this environment
like this kind of an athletic acrobatic
Spider Man would so because of that I
imagine environments are a lot more open
um more often and probably a lot taller
or more vertical more often and you know
one of my favorite parts of all the
Batman games is the predator mode soil
areas where you know you're trying to
have you're trying to avoid anyone
spotting you and you do have some
options like that in spite of my own way
you can kind of take out one guy who's
apart from everyone else but I don't
think it's going to have those full-on
credito modes while you're like hiding
in grates and sneaking up and taking
people out one by one which again my
favorite parts of those games but this
is again it's a different game so one
thing that I think they do have a fair
bit in common which I'm interested to
see how Spidey iterates on is gadgets
that you can use during combat and we
already know that insomniac is great
with gadgets too that goes even back to
the first resistance but obviously
Ratchet and Clank as well they have a
lot of creative stuff that they come up
with and they implement them internet
games really seamlessly and I think from
what I saw with this I didn't use the
gadgets as much as I should have I think
I didn't quite know what they all did in
the demo that I play cuz it's just a
fifteen-minute chunk of the game that I
imagined earlier in a tutorial or maybe
you get the gadgets progressively you'd
learn more about them and be more
inclined to use them but there is a
tripwire which i think is really cool
you can put that down on the ground if
someone walks into it it kind of webs
them I think you can even swing trip
wires together I'm not sure if that's
correct but but there are ways to kind
of chain them into other combos the web
bomb is really cool they're also just
a lot of things you can just kind of
throw at enemies to distract one while
you take on another during combat which
i think is similar to Batman I'm sure
and something I could probably get
pretty crazy with this and we'll see
some tech that I didn't see in the demo
or any of the gameplay that we've seen
online because of course they are super
creative and I am interested to see how
it comes about or like are we going to
get those gadgets progressively through
the story are we gonna have them all
that's taught I'll be going to have an
upgrade system like old from everything
that we've seen I just want to know how
it walks I want to see that stuff in
action and the sort of RPG ish elements
are really interesting to me another
thing that I think is very similar to
Ockham is the enemy types whose enemy
that had a Taser some regular guys who
didn't really have much and then a guy
who had a gun and the enemy variety for
just regular kind of drone dudes like
not bosses obviously which I sure will
be very different seem very very similar
to the optin games which is of course
very similar to a hundred other games
because that's the way action-adventure
did that's the way these kind of games
watch and then aside from that the only
thing that I'm like getting big
Salieri's from but I'm kind of
interested in is how all these villains
are going to type together I mentioned
this at the start that I actually quite
liked arkham origins it was buggy and it
crashed on me and it didn't change quite
enough about the series but i enjoyed
the story as a huge DC fan who likes a
lot of those villains i'm also a fairly
big spider-man fan and i like a lot of
the villains that we've seen shown up
there way more than i expected so I'm
kind of wondering if the story is going
to be still on origins where basically
one of those villains is sort of put a
hit on Spidey and has made it so
everyone else is trying to get at him
I'm very interested to see how that
turns out and having played previous
spider-man games the one thing that I
really don't know about that I'm really
interested in is what you can do when
you're not going through story stuff
like I did do some sidequest stuff in my
time playing and there's like you know
basic go here and fight some guys but I
mean like can I do like photography
assignments can I go to the bugle like
what what kind of stuff like that can I
do but I'm really curious about that
stuff and of course the game comes out
in September so it's not that far away
but yeah let me know if you guys have
any more questions I just wanted to
answer this one thing that I haven't
really seen many people talking about
that I've seen so people asking about
but nobody addressing
is it for me today everyone I'm Alana
and I will see you guys next time